[Music]
when i was a kid
guys like me were brought up to follow
clothes hey
circle
[Music]
what'd you say what
antonio soprano
i wonder if i can talk to you alone for
a moment mr soprano
on the basis of the sanford binet he's
high iq
you can't prove it by me he's got a d
plus average
well he doesn't apply himself but he is
smart
the results tell us he's a leader
ankle dick
[Music]
growing up with the family
takes a toll me being an ambassador to
england no pranks
you're my nephew i want to do whatever i
can
to help you
my gift to you i want to go to college
i can't get caught with [ __ ] like this
you take the speakers right
at the same time you say to yourself is
the last time i've ever steal something
it's that simple
let me go talk to him he only listens to
dickies
maybe some of the things you do
we'll make the right decision this kid's
got what it takes
as far as your nephew goes
i'm listening stay out of his life
[Music]
got yourself
[Music]
you